so ziemlich jeden tag gegen halb drei
macht sich thekla schünemann auf den weg
sie holt ihren freund lars nowak ab
thekla und las mit mitte 50 und leben in
einer wohneinrichtung der lebenshilfe
einem selbsthilfeverband für menschen
mit geistiger behinderung
insgesamt rund 100 menschen wohnen hier
in wgs mit bis zu sieben personen
manche brauchen mehr manche weniger
hilfe für alle fälle sind rund um die
uhr betreuer in den vier häusern
das tegeler und lars als paar leben
dürfen wäre anderswo unmöglich hier ist
das kein problem
es ist einfach so
wir behalten sie ihre
freunde
ein liebespaar mit down-syndrom zum
alltag in der wohneinrichtung gehören
ganz selbstverständlich die beziehungen
mit dazu die hausleitung hat vertrauen
die bewohner sollen selbst bestimmen und
entscheiden was sie wollen und was nicht
jeder mensch wünscht sich beziehungen
jeder mensch wünscht sich nähe das
steckt glaube ich egal ob mensch mit
behinderung oder ohne belohnen die jedem
menschen drin
konstantin close ist oft langweilig er
ist 32 und sehnt sich nach einer
partnerin als er zehn war für ihn ein
auto an seitdem ist er behindert wie er
sagt pädagogin marie hilft ihm wenn er
auf einem dating portal für menschen mit
beeinträchtigungen nach einer freundin
sucht
yahoo man also menschliche
penis na gut dann würde ich heute gerne
mit euch über geschlechtsteile sprechen
und zwar von mann und frau hier trifft
sich die sex und liebe gruppe jede frage
ist erlaubt wie masturbiert man
eigentlich richtig zum beispiel die
gruppe ist eines der beliebtesten
angebote der wohneinrichtung
so sieht es aus
hast du schon gesehen auch in echt
thekla und lars fahren regelmäßig
zusammen in den urlaub und da haben sie
auch schon gemeinsam übernachtet
wichtig ist der lebenshilfe dass alles
einvernehmlich und respektvoll passiert
jeder mensch darf schlafen wo er möchte
wenn dann der gastgebende partei
sozusagen einverstanden ist und
miteinander schlafen ist was wir nicht
in einem büro oder in einem gruppenraum
verhandeln sondern dass verhandelt ihr
untereinander
davon profitiert die 60 jährige sabine
hilfenhaus die in der wohneinrichtung
lebt und ihr gleichaltriger partner
helmut herrmann geltner
zusammen genießen sie das leben heute im
zoo in hannover
[Musik]
sabine hat früher darüber nachgedacht
selbst kinder zu haben als sie jung war
aber sie bekam immer wieder gesagt dass
gingen nicht
bisschen traurig ja heimlich aussuchen
ohne kennt auch
umso wichtiger ist für sabine dass sie
helmut hat und die lebenshilfe ihr die
möglichkeit zu nähe und liebe gibt